yeah hello welcome to the video to
fifteen 15 minute game again go play d4
and check quickly my opponent okay
player from from Belgium rated about
2,000 here okay let's see what Isom what
to play in the Slav goodnight f3 first
yeah often I play here the exchange
variation which seems a bit dry here for
a video ok let's go on 93 I don't really
know these lines that well now is sick
so it's going for the semi Slav well my
knowledge is really limited played this
for a while
yeah of course White's main Lisa Bishop
g5 and III here the exchange line now is
so submit harmless yeah should g5 would
be would be in the most principled move
I read in his note that he's 60 years
old so I'm speculating a bit that he
doesn't play the bot Vinick maybe are
high h6 if he goes for the blood vinegar
I'll be a be on my own unless I try to
find the book lying around here
somewhere which wouldn't be really fair
I guess okay we should be seven is going
for a classical approach let's just play
III here yeah now we got a Queens gambit
declined usually a black pin doesn't
combine the moves Bishop e7 early and c6
because some very often it's um it's an
important option for black to play c5 in
one move so it's rather unusual that
he's played this so early okay let's go
Bishop HS home it's not a bigger issue
though it's it's playable for instance
in this position I think um black has a
rather playable option of going 94 which
is very similar to to the to the Alaska
variation black only has played c6 and
set of castles but yeah very often play
sir c6 anyway so um this would be an
option here you can also of course just
castle are playing night pg7 but if he
goes tonight bd7 or castles he has to to
reckon numb with a wide set up with
Quincy to and rook t1
or even long castle sometimes but I'm
not such a huge fan of long castle in
the Queens gambit it's just a matter of
personal preference i think but it's
often a good idea yeah and it's let's go
for this Quincy to this cover c4 also so
that he cannot easily planar deform and
the idea is to play quick rookie 1g1
make it more difficult for black to get
the free move see 5 45 in so I go Rupe
d1 here usually if white tries such a
setup with Quincy to again setups was
Bishop would not be g7 usually blacks
best bet then is to play c5 in one move
and then a quick win 8-5 getting some
counter play here on this a5e one
diagonal but now he's already committed
to two having played c6 so he cannot go
for c5 anymore or only with the loss of
Temple I think c5 right now would really
weaken the center lot so I'm more or
less expecting another waiting move here
like for instance a six would be a
rather usual in such positions or maybe
also roop rupee eight just to move to to
ask white what what his next move will
be um of course white would like to UM
recapture on c4 in one move in case
black indeed captures on c4 i would like
to recapture in one move so it's this
rather old theme of fighting for tempo
with this bishop so if black goes a 6e
sort of waits for why to play Bishop d3
and then capture this is also my on a
six for instance white can consider
moves like a three or h3 too yeah sort
of wait one move and then
maybe provoke like to capture him
yup l'exposition are still is fairly
solid here move like a 6-foot since this
absolutely playable it's some
interesting question what what should do
then okay some gone I to h5 yeah the Sun
is rather unusual really and the some
kind of setup but it's not necessarily
bed of course yeah I can I can retreat
to g3 would be one option after this
year might consider to take on g3 and
play f5 maybe setting up a delayed stone
wall formation I can just capture e7
yeah the girl I go for this so the
question now is do I have some some
extraordinary option here maybe of
course I'm already committed to Rupp t1
here if I for instance would have still
the opportunity to Castle long then also
G a G for would be a really interesting
idea it's still interesting actually but
you know this is so not really my kind
of chess but yeah but it is interesting
he has played h6 this is the main point
here so I could go g4 retreats and then
g5 immediately if it takes Knight takes
this is already a quite threatening
position here of the night he cannot
easily play d 585 because I kept on d5
and take on d5 h7 is made ok I go for
this at Sur it's at least interesting
and now I g5 the idea if he if he
retreats the night or move it somewhere
I could capture h6 it should be you
should be fine for me really and if you
take sigh take with the night and then I
always have this h7 threat here 35 yeah
of course if mocking what would be on c1
here so that I can easily connect the
rooks than my position would be would be
I think absolutely great here it's um
that's not not that clear of course
let's say it takes Knight eggs um and
then the the usual reaction would be to
to do something in the center let's say
if five but this is not possible because
cd5 cg 595 and if he captures and we get
this position here if he goes if five
now cdcd 95 95 Greene 87 oops hmm
interesting yeah of course he could he
could to try this but then insult insert
some some other move let's say cd5 ed
form so this fields are really really
premature 85 hard to believe actually
okay I need to take this if it takes now
I take on d5 of the night using this
mate mate trick here so if he really
recaptures I'm d 595 he would need to
gamble the Queen somewhere and it's not
really a parent whether it should be
alright yeah but now he needs to reckon
I come I can just
take with the rook here and now my rock
might come into play over the
fourth-ranked here nice rook lift on the
fourth-ranked instead of the
third-ranked which is rather usual yeah
it's not happening in every game but
it's not so uncommon either okay let's
let's see what you could could try now I
don't think can I have a concrete threat
here I of course have various ideas to
to improve the position i can go rook g1
at some point look h4 could be an idea
get the rook on the edge file and also i
could of course just try to get the
bishop into play oh this is some this is
surprising at least I'm it's surprising
for me I thought it would be problematic
for him if I am have the chance to
pressurize f7 also okay let's check
quickly if I take on c6 here of course
he could go 95 or something playing her
but then as then I've 925 again okay
okay let's say dtext e6b texas tech's
Bishop c4 this was why I was surprised
about rupee a because I've 7s an instant
target and f7 s also really a weak spot
there
of course it can go 95
it should be three as possible c5 from
there for
that's a bit shaky in this position okay
but I could also go d 6 of course and d6
attacking the Queen Queen e5 for
instance but then I d4 would hang it
also has a knight on d5 this is look
somewhat uncomfortable yeah I don't
think I want that our taking would
really help them a bit to develop her
develop his pieces if he place this move
let's say he places next move then d6
wood really pushes clean back to some to
some passive position and he's not
really threatening anything 95 I could I
want a force very very young but i have
t 6 yeah well maybe mm-hmm just improve
the position with getting a rock on the
GF are you still cannot take here
because of night eggs on 95 I can play d
6 which sends his queen back the knight
on d5 always is a little bit threatening
because of f3 is a big hole here I've
discovered this with a knight on d5 but
it's always something to take into
account
okay but now but quite quite passive
this move what about the ad g6 Justi 625
if nothing else I can go neither three
with just a good position yeah should be
too bad but this is only only one option
our also have other rules rogue age for
Bishop c4 also you should see for if it
takes on d4 I can take f 78 this looks
looks like complete complete disaster
for black actually taking here is no big
issue I can always retreat okay ships
afar
yeah bishop there should be six now
interesting interesting point here d 7
d's havilah move Knight f3 lots of lots
of interesting moves here
let's say I applied to seven let's check
d 7
hmm
now it doesn't seem to to win to win
immediately
yeah the whole position looks are really
shaky for black but I don't see how a
really great continuation right now
which is strange well I can just maybe
I'm just overlooking something great
yeah this is not strange actually it's a
it's a complicated position of course
yeah well what I don't like here is my
knight on c3 this piece is doing nothing
really i'm wondering if maybe an 92
could be an option 92 to f4 something
like this could be an idea i'm unsure
here
yeah the night is not a great piece at
the moment another idea yeah difficult
okay I go I go this year
alrighty captured on c4 I was just
fetching me something quickly here to
drink it's not the best point with two
something on the clock but really needed
something hmmm ok at least I have a
simple threat now on F 796 looks looks
normal here question is d 7 now maybe d
727 he cannot take with the night
because I take six and then g7 is
hanging okay I could also just take you
seven but then you could catch a g5 okay
I can take you 697 this is fine now what
now do I have some something nice here
looks really like there should be should
be something now take f7 maybe don't
really see it it could also play a forum
where does the Queen go f4
it takes III I've group g3 which looks
totally insane but okay I need to do to
play quicker now maybe I'm just
blundering everything here down on 130 I
really shouldn't have taken the time to
head to get something to drink between
III rube g3 should win the Queen if I'm
not okay he what did I overlooked here
some trick or what maybe there's some
some great trick here I don't I don't
see ya I move for the Queen now can the
sacrifice for lots of material or
something I don't think so no we
couldn't okay I can also take f7 now
then deform him this is not so clear
actually
I can just reach you to a seafoam we
should try let's just grab this time
morning okay what what is this year I've
got extra night but it's still a bit get
complicated of course yeah III threaten
now let's just cover you three here they
are still a bit uncomfortable for a
couple of moves with the less time here
hmm
don't really see him how can completely
kill off his counterplay maybe 92 e 62
this threatens maybe only three again I
need to similar simplify this yes yes 93
now i am in idiot I'm a complete idiot
completely useless what this this is
still winning actually so only terrible
to do in the time yeah i know that i
want to stop your position check check
yeah this will end on the draw with
considering the time this is okay cause
I must win this check stalemate yeah at
least are secured to draw with nothing
on the clock I really should stop the
fetching drinks three minutes this is of
course should be a rather rather simple
win yeah yeah of course I've got also
night f7 but I really couldn't calculate
this at the time maybe this is this is
the easiest actually okay this is
completely winning i'm just a piece of
so yeah interesting interesting game
yeah I force winning computer grease
yeah pretty much I think without doing
any great analysis I I think I
completely out later Mia but check
Thomas sometimes just cause an issue
yeah completely overlooked that you can
take with the ii-if III rook and then
has got this bloody fork again King f2
any normal wolf is just just over yeah
okay interesting game nevertheless
thanks for watching and see you soon